hey everyone welcome to apogee up close
i'm irfan bakke i'm a customer engineer
with with google cloud i work very
closely with our customers
to help them make better cloud decisions
cloud architectural decisions
and also better api management decisions
and today we'll be talking about how to
think
beyond the gateway so let's um let's
start with the objective right
what uh what we'll be discussing today
and what you'll be getting
out of this talk is how to be successful
with your apis and have a well thought
strategy driving your api program
and just to clear a few buzzwords here
by strategy i really mean looking at not
just your apis but your
entire business and looking at the
metrics that you're using
to drive your business forward and
connect
your apis to help you achieve those
metrics right
so that as a whole is um is what we call
what we call a strategy and an api
program is
just a collaboration between
your multiple groups multiple functions
within your organization to really drive
the strategy so here's the agenda i'll
start by setting the context by giving
an example
of what a successful api program looks
like
and i'll do it through telling you about
one of our customers
that has been thinking very
innovatively about the api strategy and
their journey through multiple years on
iterating through it and really being
successful
in the api program then we will pivot
and we'll
we'll talk about how apis fit into your
company's architecture
and what different approaches you can
take to build
your api program security as we see it
is a core component
of any api strategy we'll talk about
that as well
and finally we'll tie all of this
together into
the main subject of today's call how to
look beyond the api gateway
and really think about api management as
a whole to drive your api program
and then we'll end with with questions
and answers let's dive right into it
right
so the the successful api program i want
to talk to you about
was of walgreens and it's a it's a very
interesting story
back in the days um walgreens
started as a classic
brick and mortar chain of pharmacies
and really it was no different than any
other mom-and-pop pharmacy
the difference was the scale
they had more than 8 000 stores
and the metric that they boasted was
that they had
a store within five mile distance
of 75 percent of the us population
that would have been a success criteria
right because that's how you could tell
how many people walgreens could reach
and if they were able to reach those
people they would be able to sell things
to them and that's how
they're successful but with the advent
of
the digital age we're all familiar with
how
amazon has been just disrupting a lot of
different retailers right the classic
story is
how amazon started disrupting walmart
and how walmart really had to
form a unique strategy to fight back
walgreens was a little different they
were ahead of the game
um and it basically started
as somewhat of what i would call a
coincidence
right so within the walgreens if you've
ever been in one of the stores
they have a photo lab where
people back in the days would go in to
develop their photo rolls and get the
pictures out
right so with the advent of smartphones
around
2008 um around that time
people stopped using the photo roll
cameras
and smartphones were smart enough to
take pretty decent quality images at
that time
so one of the ways walgreens was
benefiting from the photo labs was that
people come in to develop their
their pictures and as a result they
would buy something else as well
right so the foot traffic was very
beneficial to them but with the advent
of smartphones then that had gone down
so they needed to think about the
customer and
what they wanted why did they go away
and figure out how they can get them
back
turned out that they were looking they
were still looking for a way to print
their digital photos
so what they did was they created a
native
application to let the end users upload
their pictures to the app
and pick them up developed at a nearby
walgreens store to do this they had to
create and expose the necessary apis to
the internal developers
right so that they could create that
application so that was that was good
um that restored some of their traffic
not all of it
right so they said all right is there
another bigger opportunity for us
to get more foot traffic into our stores
so they they looked at how exactly were
the end users
um interacting with their photos
right what additional things were they
doing it what other additional
applications were
using to enhance their pictures it
turned out that there were plethora
of other mobile and web applications
where users
would would upload their photos for
example for holiday cards
and they would decorate the card with
their photos and off and ultimately they
would want to print it out
so they said all right how can i tap
into those applications
and somehow incentivize the developers
of those applications
to have those photos printed at
in nearby at a at a nearby walgreens
right it solved their problem of getting
uh the photos printed
and it gave more foot traffic to
walgreens
so it was in their mind a win-win
situation so what they did
was now they expanded the api program
to expose the apis to uh to partners
so that they could incorporate them into
into their application and really
created an ecosystem
so this ecosystem it started with
photo apis and expanded into
a bunch of other services that they
could offer like prescription refills
to medical and healthcare applications
like purchasing their in-store
merchandise with a partner like
postmates
like integrating walgreens reward
programs
into other partner applications and all
of that
so now with um with with expanding
into an ecosystem they're able
to really extend their reach from
one or a handful of native applications
into hundreds of partner applications
that's huge
so that was that was as a whole
an example of a successful api program
right but what made walgreens api
program successful
i think the simple answer is that they
had a relentless
focus on developers and customers right
they started with their customers first
they thought about what exactly they
wanted and they gave it to them
and the method of giving it to them was
through apis but it was still connected
to their business strategy there were
two essential parts
that played a huge role and one
of them was a developer portal and
incentives and this is how
they communicated with their developers
with their partners in addition to just
exposing the apis they also
exposed an incentive program to them
they said that hey for every dollar for
example
i'm just making numbers up but for every
dollar of revenue
that you bring in to the four-to-prince
api
for example i will incentivize you 10
cents
so now there were a lot of developers
that were making net
new photo applications just to make
revenue
um out of this program so it was it was
very popular
the second one was analytics once the
apis were being consumed
the way they really gauged how the users
and the developers were accessing
consuming the apis
gave them intel on how they could
make them better so these two components
were were crucial beyond just creating
and exposing those apis
so let's tie this back into how you
should think about
your api program right um the
the there are multiple different
approaches to build an api
program but it really boils down to two
major ones
one is a tactical approach and the other
one
is a more strategic approach so let's
talk about both of them
and see what are the pros and cons
right so um let's talk about a tactical
one first
let's make it a fun exercise all right
let's say you have
a ceo or cto of your company
come to you to say that hey i've got an
idea we have
this api service that
we should really broadcast out to our
partners
it would be a mutually beneficial move
both to us and the partners
right and he gives you the task to make
that happen
how do you do it so let's say now you
are following the tactical approach the
first thing you'll do is you'll identify
the service and you'll say hey how do i
expose this out to
let's say just one external application
for now
and the solution you come to is
just open up a firewall port right and
obviously you will need some security in
front of the service
to make sure that you're allowing just
the people that should be allowed
to access it but that's the solution
all right you open up the firewall port
you add the security
policy there the next thing is what
about rogue applications right they can
really crash your system if they call
it too too frequently in that case you
just add a rate limiting functionality
and call it a day next
what if each api call needs data from
multiple backends
how would you take care of that let's
say you have some orchestration
being performed so that an api call
comes in
talks to three four any number of
different backends
gets the response back matches it up and
passes it back to to that calling
application
now do you see what
might be a problem with this strategy
what's not in focus here
well the customer is not in focus right
you are you are really thinking about
that particular service and how you
would expose it out but you're not
really thinking about
how to who is a customer and what
experience you actually want to give
them
now let's take a look at a more
strategic way
to look at your apis what you're seeing
on the screen
right now is what we call a digital
value chain
which encompasses all of the different
entities
that would eventually in one way or the
other
interact with your apis on the left you
have your users on the right you have
your backend systems
right so traditionally what um
what what people did was think about
it from more of an exposure point of
view
and that's what i illustrated in the
previous example
you have a service and you're just
thinking about how do i expose this out
i would mitigate some of the problems
around it like security and rate
limiting that that we talked about but
essentially you just want to expose it
out
but on the other hand the success
pattern that we've seen
is the opposite right think about
the users first so when
your user is sitting on the table
opening up their laptops or interacting
with their mobile application
what is the experience that you want to
give them
once you have identified that particular
experience
then you have to think about
what kinds of applications would give
them
those experiences right and those
applications would then be made
by developers so essentially you want to
make sure you're
giving absolutely awesome apis to your
developers
so that they don't need to worry about
the complexities of your systems
and they can really focus on the
experiences that they're building for
the end users
and that's really in the hands of an api
team
and a lot of you on the call might
be part of such an api team
you would really make sure that you're
focusing
on the end user and also on your
developer
first and creating those apis designing
those apis
such that they are addressing their
needs
and eventually then you would connect
those apis to your backends
right that's where all of the
interesting data
in logic of your enterprise resides so
you would connect them to the backends
to get the data execute the logic
and all of that this is how you would
strategically view your apis but
this also poses a problem right and that
problem is from a security standpoint we
talked about
all of these entities being part
of the digital value chain but the more
entities you have
the more effort you need to put in to
make sure that they're secure
for example on the left you can have
a legitimate end user
or you can have a hacker or you can have
a bot
some bad actor that really wants to
abuse
your api you can have
really any application on the internet
interacting with
your with your apis so how do you
identify that it's the right application
that you have authenticated
um how do you de-provision access
of that application to your system if
needed so all of that's important
on the developer side who are the
developers
that are consuming your apis right are
they registered
do you know them do you are you able to
track them well
and if needed are you able to drop them
from the api program
are you able to de-provision them for
apis
are they secure enough at runtime right
are they following the best practices
and standards that your
organization has laid out both from a
regulatory
and from a compliance standpoint and
finally your backend systems
is the data coming in and out of your
backend systems
coming in and out securely is it secure
is it encrypted at rest is it encrypted
in flight
and all of that and how do you also make
sure
that you're protecting your backend
systems from
a certain overload in the api call
volume so
let's let's look at how an intelligent
api management platform
would mitigate some of these threats
and make sure that your strategy
is also taking care of security
so at apogee we actually make sure that
each of these entities are thought about
cohesively
for example for the end user you would
need behavior-based security
to identify the patterns how they're
calling your your apis
and classify them as either bad actors
or legitimate users
right you'd also want signature-based
security
to protect your systems against the
well-known osp attacks
and you might also want to do some fine
grain control like
um looking at the payload complexity um
and making sure that adheres to a
particular schema
that you have defined for requests
coming in
you may also want to protect your
backend systems from some abusive users
if they're calling you apis too
frequently and have them spike or acid
so you can do all of that on the on the
end user side
also for the applications you want to
make sure that you're identifying them
you're authenticating them through
industry standard or2 protocols
and you are restricting them or
authorizing them
to access just the apis that you give
them access to
now for your developers you may want to
make sure that these are
your trusted employees or partners and
to do so you can authenticate them
through an identity provider like octa
or ping fedrid
now talking about your apis and api
teams you'd want to make sure
that your your api teams
have access to only the apis and even
the functionalities within those
apis that they should have access to
and teams like your security team are
able to set blanket policies
for all of your apis to make sure that
your system's secure you'd be able to do
all of that
with a with an api management platform
like apogee
lastly talking about your backend
systems you would want to make sure
that the connection to them is secure
through something like mutual tls and ip
white listing
and the data that flows in and out
is encrypted both on the wire and a
trust so we talked about how to
really look at your api program
strategically right thinking about the
users first
and and also thinking about security as
you are doing it
so what exactly is needed for you to be
able to do so
the first is through developer
management
right having a portal where your
developers
can come in and learn more about your
api program
maybe part of it is your documentation
other part of it is monetization
incentives
to use your apis maybe it also has an
integration to your support portal
whatever that is but any way for you
to quickly on board and engage your
partners and developers
next is analytics right so as they start
consuming your apis
you want to see how exactly they're
consuming it
right um where are the end users located
um how are they using the applications
so
you can look at all that data and make
your api program
better the next is
operations automation so as your api
program
grows in scales you shouldn't really
need to worry about the operations
yourself
right you worry about the apis you worry
about your products
and the operations and everything else
should just happen
next is api development as you're
developing these apis one thing
to note is that they would have to be
developed quickly right your
developers and their innovation
actually depends on how fast you're
rolling out features
so that would mean that ideally you
would have
pre-baked policies like we provide in in
apogee drag and drop
really quickly change the apis iterate
them version them
and go to market faster and finally
a secure inflexible api runtime
so that you can process the incoming
requests
and the responses going out
so all of this together is
really a core part of
a good api management platform these are
features and functionalities actually
that you get right now
in apogee and one thing to note is that
a very tiny portion of this
functionality
is an api gateway so tying this back
to the original idea of our talk today
thinking beyond the api gateway when you
when you really think about the users
first and make sure
you are tying your api strategy into
your business strategy then
you would need an intelligent api
management platform to drive that api
program